[Musique]
m
c'est
bonsoir à tous édition du sky écho aux
vaccinodromes du vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines dans ce numéro
nous allons notamment parlé de la
vaccination des salariés des entreprises
de l'agglomération depuis le mercredi 12
mai dernier des créneaux sont réservés
aux collaborateurs des sociétés
saint-quentinoise
dans ce numéro focus aussi sur la
création d'entreprise durant la semaine
du 7 au 11 juin des webinaires sont
organisées sur cette thématique pour les
futurs entrepreneurs saint quentinois
enfin rencontre avec une entrepreneure
de coignières harmonie voisin dirige la
brasserie la voisine
c'est au programme de ce 18e numéro du
skate
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
or nous sommes avec philippe thomas qui
travaillent sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines alors que vous venez
de vous faire vacciner
comment vous avez entrepris cette
démarche de vaccination j'ai reçu en
fait un mail de mon entreprise qui va de
la semaine dernière tu va proposer un
créneau pour cette semaine j'ai donné
mon
mais je mets jour préférentiels et le
pain on m'a dit de me rendre focus était
acceptée et que je pouvais aller me
faire vacciner au vélodrome de 50 ans
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
démarche
qu'est ce que ça va permettre cette
vaccination ça va faciliter la reprise
de l'activité sur place oui oui c'est
tout à fait pas moi je trouve ça plutôt
bien et ça que je j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion quand j'ai eu le mail de mon
entreprise et je pense que ça va
accélérer un peu le retour un peu de
déception suscitée et surtout le retour
à la vie à la vie presque un peu plus
normal en tout cas merci philippe rémond
derrière alors on vient de croiser
sylvain et tian bonjour bonjour vous
êtes un des collaborateurs du
technocentre renault de guyancourt
vous venez de vous faire vacciner qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette démarche de
la société de l'entreprise qui vous a
permis d'accéder au vaccin
ben c'est très bien parce que jusqu'à
maintenant on avait beaucoup de
contraintes
pour trouver des centres de vaccination
et les disponibilités de créneau là en
quelques jours on nous a proposé
d'être sur liste
d'attentes et d'avoir un rendez vous
assez rapidement et en fait en quelques
jours on nous a rappelés en été sur ce
rendez vous et je suis venu aujourd'hui
donc c'était assez rapide et ça c'est
très agréable
[Musique]
et avec tout une collaboratrice du
technocentre renault de guyancourt julie
glace bonjour bonjour alors vous venez
de vous faire vacciner
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
démarche que l'entreprise vous
accompagne dans cette démarche pas je
trouve ça vraiment formidable qu'on nous
accompagne dans cette démarche
vaccination ça permet de protéger déjà
nous en premier mais aussi de participer
à la lime unity collectif tout ça très
très bien ça va changer quelque chose
aussi après dans l'organisation du
travail ça va peut-être facilité aussi
la reprise d'activité je pense que oui
tout à fait ça nous permettra de
retourner au technocentre plus
facilement et de retrouver une vie
beaucoup plus normal donc c'est très
bien
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint jean michel fourgous
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines bonjour président
alors voilà plusieurs deux semaines
maintenant mercredi 12 mai vous avez
lancé la vaccination pour les salariés
de l'agglomération quel premier bilan
vous faites de cette opération
alors je vous rappelle que saint quentin
est une des agglomérations en france on
a 30 mines de paris gros un des plus
gros pib français par habitant donc le
monde de l'entreprise est très important
donc le le bilan c'est que on a vacciné
la première cible sensibles qui sont les
plus de 25 ans qui avait qui a
représenté 90% des décès comme id donc
priorité ok maintenant
après on a bien sûr et les profs les
policiers les pompiers
je dirais les assesseurs des bureaux de
vote
donc plusieurs cibles mais maintenant
c'est les entreprises et d'entreprises
ce sont eux qui nous font manger qui
font manger les français qui assure leur
votre retraite qui paye les hôpitaux qui
paye les routes qui paient les mairies
ou sumer donc faut être conscient que
les actifs qui quittera va qui
produisent la richesse qu'ils produisent
50% du chiffre d'affaires nous redonner
en en 1 en social en impôts sociale et
fiscale à l'état c'est pas l'état qui
vous fait manger c'est l'entreprise il
faut bien donc leur maintenance est la
priorité
alors on est dix sept mille entreprises
de saint quentin on en a déjà près de
500 qui se sont inscrits mais faut aller
beaucoup plus loin
puisque en gros on est déjà un objectif
de dix mille salariés qui vont se faire
vacciner ici donc c'est en train de se
dérouler mais il faudra aller bien au
delà comment ça s'organise pour les
entreprises comme un affront pour venir
se faire vacciner ici eh bien elle se
branche sur une adresse mail cd&v codé
avait eu ses hauts
@ est-ce qu y point fr voilà pour bien
sûr envoyer leur liste de salariés mais
toutes les entreprises et 17000
entreprises de cinq roumains sont
aujourd'hui prioritaire parce qu'il faut
relancer l'économie laisse que si vous
renoncez pas l'économie les surprises
vont ils ne vont pas de très bonne donc
aujourd'hui c'est prioritaire c'est ça
aussi la vaccination va permettre de
faciliter cette relance économique en
cours en france aujourd'hui
oui parce que il ya eu plusieurs gestes
forts qui ont étaient envoyées à
l'entreprise d'abord il ya une prise en
charge des salaires de gens qui
n'étaient plus en production
vu le risque bien sûr d'aller travailler
il ya eu des tags des aides aux
entreprises
honnêtement dans le monde la france a
fait un effort il faut le dire ne sais
si je pas d'accord tu vois des décisions
mais là au niveau économique c'est un
soutien très fort qui va coûter cher
certes mais cela a coûté beaucoup plus
cher de lâcher ces entreprises que de
les soutenir même dans cette période
bien sûr de passivité
donc voilà alors après il ya la
vaccination pour le redémarrage
bien sûr le plus vite possible mais il
n'empêche qu'on aura certainement de la
casse il demeure que on aura des
entreprises
il faudra aussi avoir une proximité avec
eux c'est ce que l'on fait au
développement économique de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors c'était le 11 juin 2020 l'année
dernière vous votiez le plan de relance
de saint quentin en yvelines 2 millions
d'euros à travers le fonds résilience
que vous avez abonder ces implants de la
région vie que vous avez abondé vous
avait abondé aussi le fond initiative
sky pour soutenir peut-être les start up
de du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et puis il ya eu aussi la
compensation des loyers qui n'étaient
pas payés par les commerces
quel bilan vous faites de toutes ces 10
de tous ces dispositifs que vous avez
mis en oeuvre ce sont des millions
d'euros vous l'avez compris les
différentes classifications aux effets
de la ces des aides aux entreprises mais
mais je dirais que si vous laissez
tomber ces entreprises ça vous coûtera
beaucoup plus cher que les mêmes si la
poutre cher de les aider mais mais on
est dans ce message on est avec eux
c'est l'entreprise c'est la vie juillet
l'entreprise donné 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires à l'état et à n'existera plus
et dans ceux qui se trompent
donc on est tous dans le même bateau et
je crois que d'ailleurs il faut le dire
cette crise a révélé des moments de
solidarité assez impressionnant c'est
vrai que c'est dans les circonstances
exceptionnelles qu'on découvre des
comportements exceptionnel les français
sont particulièrement bon quand ils ont
daumur et on l'a senti et je pense que
c'est pas encore totalement réglé mais
je suis assez optimiste quand j'ai vu
les comportements assez exemplaire dans
cette crise
au niveau économique au niveau social et
on rappelle justement le site internet
de l'adresse mail pour s'inscrire pour
venir se faire vacciner ici un mail que
vous pouvez adresser au développement
économique pour venir inscrire vos
salariés si vous souhaitez qu'ils soient
vaccinés merci jean michel fourgous
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et le sky échos se
poursuit ici au vaccinodromes de 50 ans
d'oubli produire une bière bio et local
c'est le choix qu'a fait harmonie
voisins en ouvrant la brasserie la
voisine à coignières en 2020 une
activité entreprise malgré la crise
sanitaire avec conviction et passion
rencontre avec harmonie voisins une
découverte signé astrid bergère et
bérangère brook
[Musique]
je m'appelle harmonie voisins j'ai 32
ans je dirige la brasse que la voisine
qui est située à coignières et je
travaille dans cette hogra s'y colle mon
activité consiste à fabriquer de la
bière
donc je travaille le malt d'orge les
houblons lots et je transforme tout ça
on dire moi je produis à coignières donc
j'aime en local qui fait 100 mètres
carrés où toutes mes cuves sont
installés je fabrique sur place je vends
sur place et
je vends que localement en termes
d'organisation moi je brasse deux jours
par semaine
après une fois par semaine forcément
faut que je mette en bouteille de bière
et puis après il ya tout le
conditionnement donc l'étiquetage des
bières la mise en carton et puis après
pages livres mais professionnels voilà
tout ce qui est bar-restaurant caviste
magasin de produits bio aux produits
locaux
et puis je travaille aussi avec les
particuliers puisque je fais des marchés
tous les dimanches matins alors la bière
parce que déjà la base moi j'aime bien
la voir donc l'idée c'était de voilà si
c'était possible de le produire à petite
échelle et on y fait c'est possible donc
c'est vraiment agréable c'est le do it
yourself fois c'est fait votre produit
consommé l'eau ça c'est un aspect qui me
plaît beaucoup
[Musique]
l'entrepreneuriat c'est vraiment
beaucoup d'indépendance pouvoir prendre
cette décision soit même et voilà
avancer à son rythme et voilà je me sens
libre aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai plaisir de venir tous les
jours à la brasserie cette année c'est
vrai qu'avec cette perspective de
réouverture des bars et des restaurants
je pense que vraiment l'activité va
repartir les gens sont heureux de sortir
consommer des produits locaux aussi
c'est vrai que les gens sont venus sur
les produits locaux et c'est vraiment
génial et donc je pense que pour pour la
bière ça présage que du bon pour
l'avenir
un événement à noter dans vos agendas du
7 au 11 juin c'est la semaine de la
création d'entreprise
un rendez vous organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines des webinaires sont
organisées tout au long de la semaine
pour conseiller et orienter les
personnes souhaitant se lancer dans une
aventure entrepreneuriale
les liens sont affichés en bas de
l'écran pour vous inscrire et nous en
profitons pour vous parler des
différentes étapes de la création
d'entreprise les détails dans ce
décryptage
[Musique]
et
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi édition à revoir en replay
sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]